est un système de dépôt d'information,
c'est-à-dire une entité qui retient ces informations à votre place,
et ne les dévoile à un tiers
que si certaines conditions pré-établies sont remplies,
comme une correspondance.
L'application que nous avons créée est destinée aux campus.
Mais le même type de système pourrait être utilisé dans l'armée,
ou sur n'importe quel lieu de travail.
Nous ne sommes pas obligés de vivre dans un monde
où 99 % des violeurs s'en sortent impunément.
Nous pouvons bâtir un monde
où ceux qui commettent des crimes en sont tenus responsables,
où les victimes reçoivent le soutien et la justice qu'elles méritent,
où les autorités reçoivent les informations nécessaires,
et où de véritables moyens sont mis en place
pour dissuader d'enfreindre les droits d'autres êtres humains.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)